here are the things that run through my
mind I would say the primary thing I'd
probably ask myself is is this action
going to lead to somebody showing up at
my funeral if you really ask me what the
[ __ ] I do for a living it's that I'm
trying to create a legacy because I'm
either a so egotistical that I want that
or be loved human being so much because
I do and so I think I've popped on
social now so I think a lot of what I
think about is what's the legacy of this
maneuver like right now this is [ __ ]
stupid for me doing an interview with
you for 15 minutes is [ __ ] ridiculous
I love it makes no goddamn sense but I'm
feeling pretty good about the odds of
maybe this leading to you showing up to
my funeral like like yeah that's how I
think about stuff so so I'm very big on
how what does it impact how does it
impact me and more importantly the other
person in the narrative that I care
about which is I think I was gifted with
some real crazy [ __ ] enough talent to be
able to do my thing for me and still
have so much left over to give so much I
mean that to me is crazy
[Music]